do steroids work if you're not like
going to the gym I mean could they do
not but for athletes they have a
significant advantage and they allow you
to recover much quicker there's certain
Sports well if you call bodybuilding a
sport right it's impossible it's
impossible without steroids some of
these guys are just yeah you cannot get
to that size you don't get to Ronnie
Coleman's size you don't get to like
Dorian yat size you don't get there
without St but you you can get cut I
think you can get like low body fat
without taking illegal stuff probably
but you probably can't get the muscules
with you're saying oh you can get very
big without taking steroids there's a
lot of people that are massive without
taking steroids there's a lot of people
that have fantastic genetics there's a
lot of people that have just thick heavy
builds you know it's natural like
there's many many people like that but
to get to the size of a bodybuilder is
superum it's not possible without
steroids that that is a science project
when you look at these people that have
just traps that start the top of their
ears and boulders for sure bowling ball
shoulders that is just that's not
possible I've met many people that are
really fit and look [__] huge and
they they don't do steroids there's a
lot in the UFC the UFC usada tests
everybody so they'll show up at your
house at 6:30 in the morning wake up sir
we need a uh urine test and we need a
blood sample and they do that all the
time and these jacked people don't get
caught they either they're doing it so
sophistic ated that even with usada
which is the most sophisticated
anti-doping program that we have
available so there's some short acting
testosterone supplements that you can
take that particularly now apparently
there's some new ones they leave the
body in like 2 and a half hours so you
can take them and get an elevated level
of testosterone you could take them
multiple times a day and it doesn't
affect your natural testosterone
production and it also uh doesn't show
up if you get past that 2 and a half
hour window so there could be a lot of
people who are just roll in the dice I
see I see how do the weigh-ins work cuz
one of the things I was going to mention
is you know to to when you weigh
something like how what are you
comparing anything the weighin are
sanctioned cheating that's what it is it
is 100% sanctioned legal cheating it's
more than fasting they they use very
sophisticated methods uh this guy sugar
Shan Ali who just won the bantamweight
title Dan Gardner is his uh nutritionist
and uh I was actually just going back
and forth with him um on Instagram
because I watched one of the videos that
he did and I was like that is really
impressive stuff they're detailing how
they cut weight and one of the things
they do is they eliminate carbs like
very close out and they they do all
these different things to water load so
your body gets used to like dumping
water out a lot there's like it's very
sophisticated so when a guy weighs in in
this case uh sugar Shan weighed at 135
lbs he's 135 lbs for all of like an hour
or so and then he weighs in and when he
fights he'll be in the 150s he'll be
somewhere in the 150s and that's mild
his opponent alamine Sterling is
absolutely massive for the weight class
so aljamain even though he weighs in at
135 pounds he's walking around I've seen
him walking around in the 170s wow 135
is my birth weight he's a big well he's
not that small when you stand next to
him like he's [__] shredded there's
no way that guy's 135 lb I mean 135 lb
person is fairly small man yeah [__]
jacked and so it's a magic trick the
best at it is this guy Alexa Alexa who
was the middleweight champion he weighs
in at 185 pounds he fights at 220 plus
he's so massive like you cannot believe
is there a technique to put on weight
Health like safely before a fight like
is just
drinking it's not it's not safe it's
very bad guys are compromising their
100% it's very bad for your organs it's
very bad for your body but okay so
that's him that's 135 lbs how the [__] I
weigh 200 so look at me next to him he's
[__] gigantic and I think he's if not
the best weight cutter in the sport him
and paa they're in the running for it
because paa this guy you can't you can't
um when he weighs in um I don't see the
actual weigh in I go there for the
ceremonial weigh and he's already put on
probably 10 pounds of water by time so
that's him weighing in and he's is
cheeks are sucked in and he'll gain
literally 40 lbs almost between them and
fight night it's [__] bananas they
did a study I think in the 80s with
Olympic hopefuls and they said uh they
made the following test as sprinters
they said would you uh would you trade
the following uh a gold medal guaranteed
gold medal at the next games uh if it
meant you die at age 35 they all say yes
they all say oh like half of them said
yes the other ones are losers but
oh